so fantastic I had the sketch already I
added a few more details onto it to work
out what was going on now I'm ready to
identify my integrals I've kind of
already started by looking at these
boundaries so let's have a look at a1 a1
like we said before is going to be the
red graph f of X take away the blue
graph G of X so I'm going to write
here's my integral I've identified that
it starts at negative 3 and it goes to 0
and then I just want to be careful with
my my terms here in collecting like
terms there's going to be this what do I
got here I'll use yellow this f of X up
here take away this G of X now I've got
a a kind of ace up my sleeve which is
the fact that when I was working out the
points of intersection I kind of already
did f of X take away G of X did you
notice it it's right up here in this
line here in this line here I've got f
of X on the left hand side and what I
did was I wanted everything to be equal
to 0 on the right hand side remember
that so I subtracted everything from G
of X already that's kind of handy so
this line here on the left hand side
this is going to be my f of X takeaway G
of X and so I don't need to do some
extra working out I've already evaluated
it so I'm going to go ahead and I'm
going to pop that into my integrand so
I'm going to put in X cubed plus x
squared minus 6 X with respect to X now
once you also remember where did I get
that from where I got this guy from is f
of X take away G of X because it was a
top function subtracting the bottom
function ok so I'm ready to go let's
let's start integrating this thing I'm
gonna have is there any simplification I
can do not not really not that makes it
easier for me so I'm going to go
straight to the primitive I'm going to
get X to the 4 on 4 plus X cubed on 3
takeaway now this is going to become 6x
squared on 2 which is 3x squared and I'm
an evaluating that from negative 3 to 0
okay I'm looking to see if there's any
common factors that
I can take out no no Numerical common
factors I can take out I can't take the
exes out because they're things I'm
gonna have to substitute values into so
even though there's an x squared as a
common factor I can't take that out so
I'm going to go ahead and start
evaluating now so the top boundary is
really nice if you have a look carefully
this is gonna be 0 on 4 + 0 + 3 - 3 lots
of 0 so all of that gives me the 0
there's the top boundary then I'm going
to subtract and now it's time to
evaluate the bottom boundaries so let's
see here negative 3 to the power 4 my
negatives will cancel 3 to the power of
4 is 81 I'm gonna get the next one 3
cubed is 27 over 3 and then I'm
subtracting 3 lots of oh sorry that's a
bit sneaky I didn't catch a mistake that
I myself made I'm not actually doing 3
cubed I'm doing negative 3 cubed so in
fact that should be a negative 27 right
the top bit glad I fixed that maybe you
spotted it before I did then here I've
got this 3 and negative 3 squared does
get rid of the negatives so there's
gonna be an iron hanging out down the
bottom bit okay
I'm gonna drop off that 0 I'm gonna
write a negative here I've got 81 on 4
let's tidy up what's happening inside
the brackets here I've got minus 27 on 3
but minus 27 on 3 is 9 and then I've got
another minus 27 hanging out there ok
looks to me like I can do some further
work that looks like - this is going to
be 20 and 1/4 and then I'm subtracting 9
and then I'm subtracting 27 that's
that's 36 I've been trying to get rid of
that minus sign out the front for a
while now in my brain so I'm going to do
that now by reversing the order of this
difference here and if I subtract the 20
I get 16 subtract another quarter you
get 15 and 3/4 ok so there's a 1 I'm
finished right how did I get that I was
doing this f of X takeaway G of X and
then off I went
alright now if I just shuffle this over
to one side I think I'll have enough
space to have a go at a to just in
parallel here so you can see me combine
them so a - what's it going to be equal
to now remembering that a - is on on our
graph it's what we switch over from
instead of red take away blue enemy blue
take away red so in other words what am
i integrating instead of f of X take
away G of X it's going to be G of X take
away f of X now you can go ahead and you
can work this whole thing out from
scratch again if you like but what I'm
always trying to do because
mathematicians are famously lazy is I'm
trying to minimize the amount of work
I've done and if I've done something
already that will help me evaluate this
then I'd like to take advantage of that
rather than do things again from scratch
now the thing that I noticed and this is
going to come up frequently right it's
one of the tricks we learnt with the
properties of definite integrals is I
can take out a factor of negative 1 here
and what that does is it reverses the
order of my difference and you can go
ahead and you can expand this to prove
it to yourself right if I expand this
new set of brackets here the minus
attaches to the F which is what I wanted
over here and then this negative and
this negative will cancel meaning I get
a positive G of X which is what I wanted
now the reason why this is useful to me
is I already know what f of X minus G of
X is I calculated it earlier and then I
used it again over here in this definite
integral so I'm just going to take
advantage of the fact that I already
have worked that out my integral has new
boundaries because we worked out before
a true starts at a different spot and
ends at a different spot it's gonna go
from 0 to 2 so let's go ahead and put
those boundaries in 0 and 2 and now
instead of writing G of X take away f of
X I'm just going to go straight to 2
this right it's the negative of the
integrand that I worked out earlier
which is over here so let's go ahead and
put a minus sign out the front and it's
X cubed plus x squared minus 6x now
because that minus sign it's a negative
1 right that's what it's short for
negative 1 times all that wrists all the
rest that stuff because it's just a
numerical coefficient I'm just gonna
bring it out the front gonna factorize
it or you can see I do that as much as I
possibly can because it makes it easier
for my brain to handle one thing I don't
have to worry
and also now that I've got that minus
sign out of the way what's great is this
is something I've integrated already
right so I can say oh this result over
here this primitive function I'm just
gonna use it all over again in fact I'm
gonna be exceptionally lazy and I'm just
going to straight-up copy it so
duplicated over to here BAM my
integration is done and now I'm going
from don't forget you got a minus sign
at the front there hanging it out from
the previous line you can see I've just
carried it forward there now I'm just
going to pop in my new boundaries which
is I think we said zero to two okay
let's start evaluating this see so I've
got a minus at the front be careful
because that applies to everything I'm
about to write so I'm going to draw some
big enormous brackets here okay the
first one is to oops
write that a bit small occurs on top of
a fraction two of the four on four which
I'm just going to write that 16 your
powers are to come up a lot so it's
handy to know them to the power of three
is 8 over 3 minus 3 lot so 2 squared
which is 4 so that right there that's my
top boundary and I'm gonna subtract my
lower boundary but you might remember um
I evaluated this same boundary before
and I just got 0 right so you can see
I'm going to subtract 0 there and then
I'm going to end my big enormous braces
there okay what have I got so I've got a
minus sign and then I'm gonna have a 4
plus 8 over 3 what's that going to be
equal to 2 that's 2 and 2/3
that's why mixed numeral and I'm gonna
subtract 12 that 0 is gone now so don't
worry about it I've got a minus sign
again you can see I've got 6 and 2/3
take away 12 and I should point out like
at this point you may well have pop this
into your calculator already and that's
fine but I do try to avoid putting in
like see something like this line over
here or this line over here sometimes it
takes just as much time to pop it into
your calculator and the disadvantage is
that if you pop it into your calculator
wrong you have no idea that the answer
is wrong it just faithfully returns to
you the answer that you asked for even
if you ask for the wrong thing and did
the same thing that I did before here
with double subtraction so six and
two-thirds and you can go ahead and
check if I'm getting that arithmetic
correct so take a deep breath what am I
done
I have used my sketch to work out what
on earth was going on I had to find
points of intersection from the sketch
and then I identified the integrals I've
evaluated them now now I'm ready to
close things off I'm going to say
therefore the total area is you know add
these two things together 15 and 3/4
plus 5 and third and this time I am
going to reach through my calculator
which I did prepare this time because I
am I knew that I would have something
like this and the common denominators I
can do but yeah it's just a bit of a
headache so I know that the 15 and the 5
are going to give me 20 but 3/4 plus 1/3
my common denominator of course is going
to be 12 so I got 13 over 12 which is 1
and 1/12 so 21 and 1/12 units squared
that's going to me my area so there was
a lot there right you had to carefully
go through this and you had to work out
where your integrals are what your what
your boundaries are which is sort of a
question all of its own and the reality
is you would often get given some of
this information or you'd have to work
out like the points of intersection you
might have had to work that out in an
earlier part if this was posed to you in
an exam so we know that you can do that
part you do it separately and then all
this work of integration comes in later